[Musik]
meine freunde und ich habe letztens gta
gespielt und ich habe einfach die
aufnahme laufen lassen also habt spaß
bei dem video oder habt keinen spaß weil
es total bescheuert geworden losgeht da
die angst weg das war zwar im video
[Musik]
alles gut kein problem ja ich habe
gleich ja ja ja die andere seite das
andere links weil ich nehme dir mal ein
bisschen ich wollte mich auch hier
hinten wollte ich auch noch ein bisschen
was verändert haben ja ja das
herausnehmen nein ich denke auch man
alter noch das war mir das war mir
wichtig dass man da haben und dass man
das ganze video aller zeiten ich zeigte
jetzt meine karre wende bereit dafür
bist ok wie macht man die taschenlampe
geht nicht gibt's nicht
hornbach alles gut
nein ich zeig dir meine karibik gut
das ist wirklich die treppen laufen
wir warten jetzt sagt darüber klettern
da ich die alter kraft oder kaffee forza
bei dem reiter habe ich das ab gemacht
weil ich mag diesen industrial locks
schau mal was hier mega mega krass oder
ich hab ja ja ja man das ist die hamas
krabbelalter das ist heftig
das ist so geil laut cas- richter
alter sein als die hälfte hey hallo
knapp und trotzdem und sonst so ja denn
deiner meinung
ich war ist das feuer dass das feuer
kann man der einlauf anbrennen
er kratzt das sehr heftig war wirklich
ich liebe geht er auch einfach so und so
geil ich will dir kurz meine karre
zeiten kommen damit läuft so mit mir
ich freue mich du fährst er hat an
dieser gruselige type hinterher fährt
dann ja ganz normal ja dann komm ich
zeig dir meine karre weil es ist völlig
erholt was ziemlich alles super es ist
für mich eine ziemlich neue aktionen
gerade dass ich meinen freunden mein
auto präsentieren
ja hier ist nichts
jetzt übrigens links ist mein auto so
vehement dass wir das hier das ist
da kann man ganz daran ja sehr gut sehr
stark geht nicht
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dollar ja
genau
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir es ja quasi zeigt jetzt
meine mutter hatte absoluten auto heraus
[Musik]
wir sind und bleiben ist die unterart
unter wasser ja die jetzt noch die
bediener links
dieses jahr sind das ist meine mutter
erscheinen sie angucken beim besitzen
die steigen ich habe immer noch keinen
kein leben verloren
ich bin tot du hast ein auto vorne hier
erwarte ich komme ich hier nochmal kurz
noch mal schwimmen ist habe ich ihn
wasser geparkt mein auto achtung du
fällst ja ich würde mir schon zu dir gar
kein problem für mich ich war ja früher
leistungsschwimmer musst du dass das
mein auto aus kassel an das cool habe
ich kann ja nicht rein
doch doch ich habe einfach drauf los du
musst nur noch dann halten ja ja alles
gut ich bleibe stehen weil ich fahre mal
hier hoch ja macht das
[Musik]
geil hatte hier vor ort ist mein auto
wirklich da schau ich zeige euch jetzt
mal meinen mann eigentlich ins auto das
nämlich dass hier muss um damit gruppe
das ist das ist mein auto die kunden
später
[Musik]
komm jetzt
davey steigt jetzt steigt jetzt ein ich
will meine haut zeigen
da soll ich einsteigen wo ich aufzeige
da genau da steigt jetzt wieder ein
willst du mein haus sehen was wollt ihr
denn zeigen die stadt ein bisschen die
stadt ein bisschen okay ja da kann ich
dir aber auch mein haus zeigt also das
ist ja quasi direkt in der stadt das
geile meinem haus ist das ist halt
ziemlich ziemlich groß ich bin ziemlich
reich und das ich habe gerade mal so ich
will ihnen meine wohnung reingeflogen
aus versehen ja irgendwann automuseen
ist oder nicht ja nehmen weil sie zeigt
dass mein auto
ich will dein auto nicht sehen hier wird
man autos sagst du ich will ich will
dein auto nicht sehen
ich holte kurz moment ich will es ist so
wenig hohl kurz mein auto ja was ich
nicht sehen wird genau das wo zu sehen
sondern darum wie ich habe jetzt mal
mein auto hier gerade außer garage
abgeholt ich weiß nicht ob du sehen
möchtest aber ist man auch eigentlich
herzlich egal weil ich würde wirklich
gern zeigen
ich fahre einfach dazu den imbiss bereit
ja wo ist nur kurz von der polizei wird
also ich habe kein motorrad gestundete
so dass man hier ist ein auto alter das
was cool
hammergeil dass das auto leute bei
fahren kann es heftig auch entspannt man
nochmal alter das gras warte wenn ich
nach vorne gehen und manchmal normal
geht das dann auch
doch geht auch alter dass er kraft hatte
gehen aber zurück wartet wenn ich mich
wenn ich nicht hingucken alter das war
megageil alter das ist ja normal heftig
ich glaube mein auto also das ist ja
mega entspannt was man mit dem auto
alles machen kann das ist glaube ich von
mir das auto so dass autos von dir ja
zum ich mir eben bringen lassen von
meinem mechaniker das kann ja eigentlich
gar nicht sein dass glauben dass mein
auto ist eigentlich mein auto
schon vor mir wo bist du gerade will
zwar lauter sehen ja hallo gab ja macht
ja keinen spaß wenn du mich die ganze
zeit hört ist das vollkommen war die
frage ist auch wie ich hätte aber gern
noch was anderes von mir hier in gta
zeigen
ja und zwar in meinem haus zu haus
ich habe ich habe ein haus sollte jetzt
meine wohnung zeigen ja ja die ist hier
links kommt über ihre wahl damit bist du
sicher dass du gerade von der polizei
gehen kommt jetzt hier runter zu nehmen
muss nur dagegen treten ja ist weiter
sehr gut
man muss ich man muss sich immer boxen
vor der tür damit man reinkommt sehr gut
so kommt sap auf jetzt bitte mal auf
mama auf bin jetzt tot
ich lade dich dann dann nächste woche
einfach ein
[Musik]
ich sage jetzt mein haus aber jetzt voll
alter jeweils auch kein bock mehr noch
länger wie die scheiße aufzunehmen ist
der strand ja ich wohne ja auch am
strand das hier das ist mein das achte
mann aus dem rhein kommen zeigt 76 mit
aus es war doch gar abschließen werden
aber schlägt er mich denn ja das
eigentliche besitzer von sendai das ist
der hausmacht du bist du bist du bist ok
ok ja also das jetzt mein haus
[Musik]
schleichen die ich schleiche ich
wirklich auf und davon mein grundstück
ein paar sekunden später beim 1 autos
die jetzt noch eine allerletzte sache
die ich mir wünsche für das ende dieses
videos ist dass wir zusammen der runde
auf dem roller coaster gehen ist bereits
sehr gut kein beschluss geht liegt hier
so schnell wieder
ja das war doch eine schöne
achterbahnfahrt
meine lebensfreude frankreich
wahrscheinlich weiß dass er jetzt gerade
war das frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt
auch ich wollte eigentlich revier wie
gta aufnehmen habe ich jetzt auch
gemacht aber irgendwie ein bisschen
anders geworden als ich es mir
vorgestellt habe wenn es euch dennoch
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video her da schocken denn die
infobox dann auf reges kanal haben wir
auch gta gespielt das ist der da und das
war ich und das war mein kopf und das
video ist jetzt auch endlich vorbei
[Musik]